what we have uh so hello everyone my
name is sparsh and I'm the marketing
manager here at Pine biotech so I'll
quickly guide you through the
registration steps and the different
resources which you'll have access to if
you'll enroll in a bioinformatics and
data science research fellowship program
so here is the landing page of the
research fellowship program and you can
go through with this particular page
after the session gets over and if you
feel any query so later on I'll share
the email address on which you can ping
and we can discuss it further
comprehensively now moving further so
this is a research fellowship program as
uh discussed earlier this particular
program is not for only biosciences
students anyone from any background
whether it is a computer science student
or a student from a Pharma background
anyone can join this particular program
and can start analyzing complex life
science data and become first in
bioinformatics now how so this
particular research fellowship program
we have designed in such a way that we
will be uh like we'll be
we'll be teaching you we'll be training
you from Basics then we'll be
transacting you from Basics to
intermediate and then from intermediate
to advanced level and then we'll be
guiding you how you can or how any
participant can develop a research
project after uh gaining appropriate
conceptual as well as practical
knowledge based on their
it is such interest so uh now scrolling
down so these are the three basic steps
or these are the like stages which one
need to go through so the first stage in
a very Layman language at the first
stage is to get yourself trained so uh
like as sonalika showed you the omics
logic learn portal so there are
different data types on which you can
work on uh for example genomics for
example transcriptomics metagenomics
epigenomics then there is a new
immersion field called space omic so uh
those who are having interests in
multinomic fields then there is a field
called data science in our data science
in Python then machine learning then we
have
um some specialization tracks like
Precision medicine neurosciences
infectious diseases Etc So based on your
research interest the mentors will guide
you which all courses you need to take
up and you need to go through so that
you gain that appropriate conceptual
knowledge which will help you eventually
in your next stage so that you can come
up with a good research question prepare
a good methodology come up with the data
set on which you need to eventually work
on and finally develop a research
project so the first thing is get ready
through training so topics what we'll be
covering is Introduction to
bioinformatics and basics of data and
Life Sciences so that you get to know
about the insights on the glimpse of
what exactly is bioinformatics different
terminologies uh different Healthcare
applications and how bioinformatics is
being used in translational research Etc
then we'll be guiding you through omics
data types like genomics transcriptomics
or metagenomics then data science and
machine learning for non-engineers and
biologists and then are in Python
Programming and in-depth analytics for
complex omics data so these are the
topics which is there in our omix logic
loan portal and based on your research
interest you can opt one and start
learning and start gaining the Train the
training now for some of the top some of
the points which you need to remember
while you are in your research
fellowship program that is you should
make sure that your research question is
compelling to those already in the field
it should be Noble second set specific
parameters to answer the research
question conclusively
find a data set that fits your
objectives and explore them for batch
effects or bias and fourth get feedback
from our expert mentors on your topic
and Analysis proposal so in the first
stage you'll get yourself trained and in
the second stage you will start working
by reviewing literature extensively then
once your research question is fixed on
which you need to work on you'll fix a
data set or which uh like do the
analysis once your data set is finalized
you'll start preparing the methodology
on it or that you need to follow so that
you can come up with the results and in
the end do the statistical or the
biological interpretation of those
results and in the end whatever you have
done you need to prepare a kind of
report or a manuscript so as to submit
now what are the potential outcomes of
This research fellowship program when
you'll join number one is expert
feedback and overall evaluation of
project quality Innovation analysis
execution so you will be getting
feedback not only from our Pine biotic
mentors but also from our industry
expert now second is the poster
presentation at the research fellowship
meeting or a research symposium so we
organize buy a new omics research
Symposium where our participants get an
opportunity to present their research
project what they have done till now and
also gets exciting uh prizes cash prizes
after the results are up so the third is
path to collaboration with expert
mentors or faculty at partner
universities and the last but not the
least path to a full publication
as you scroll down you will find three
different tenures
now there are three different tenures on
which one can work on rather I would say
four different tenures one is 45 days
another is 60 days then it's 90 days and
then is 180 days or six months in all
the four tenures the com the resources
are you will have access to the
asynchronous courses that is uh you will
have access to the omics logic loan
portal where you will be covering basic
still Advanced training courses and
lessons then you will have access to the
Hands-On assignments you will have
access to the group sessions you will
have access to the omics logic program
access educational Cloud pipelines
online Venture Support Online technical
support
Etc so these are the resources which one
would have access to when they will
enroll for this particular program now
the resources are same but the outcome
for or outcome is different for all
three or four uh tenures the outcome for
45 days is a literature review and a
project report then for 60 days it's
literature review project report and a
research poster for 90 days its
literature review project report and a
research paper publication same goes for
180 days also now the question arises
how one can enroll and like the payment
checkout links for the research
fellowship program and how one can
proceed with the payment uh so here we
have provided with all four payment
checkout links and if anyone is from low
income country so if the scholarship
opportunities are available and you can
reach out to us at the given uh
mentioned or email address that is
marketing at the omxlogic.com and we
will be providing you with like the best
possible way like helping you out with
the best possible way so that you can
enroll in this particular program and
start with and get started with the
training and the research part so now uh
moving back to the payment checkout for
example if someone is interested in 45
days you need to Simply click on this
link it will be redirected to the
payment page
so it's taking a little bit tighten yeah
so now what you need to do is you need
to Simply uh you know add uh put some of
your details over here payment
information
Etc and click on the payment of pay or
pay button and you'll be uh like
the uh you will be uh done with the
payment part so by this uh your payment
is done and after one
as your payment is done we'll be
organizing an orientation session of
yours where we'll be navigating you
through the both the platform status or
mixed logical and portal and the T by
info server as soon Alika showed you now
here are some of the student projects uh
which is being published on our mix
logic loan portal and these projects are
on different domains as you can see some
students have worked on infectious
diseases some on space or make some on
Precision oncology then machine learning
and modeling skin diseases data-driven
drug Discovery Etc so this was a little
brief about the research fellowship
program the resources which one would
have access to the different domains on
which you can work on the different
tenures and the payment process so if
anyone is having any kind of question
related to registration step payment Etc
please feel free to Ping in the chat box
and I'll be there to assist and answer
your question thank you